welcome to this video playing kabul task
in kabul task from Denmark and I'm
plating before and what can i play here
maybe let's see some variety i always
play Knight c3 m-maybe I can can do for
for fianchetto it's not a bad line at
all ok Kingsley Indian fianchetto now
black chooses the line ok this is one of
the more modern approaches knight c6
usually combined with a six or e five so
you went for a six after a six and white
has some multiple options h3e form d 5
as them is the the oldest m continuation
can I have totally forgotten what this I
going on here I think this is also
possible let's let's just do that this
prepares the night urn night and look
see one in case of b5 ok so he it seems
he's trying to quickly and get any five
so i want to i want to prevent that and
taking the knight on c6 hmm interesting
very interesting if I go queen bee three
there is 95 that's not good
to all 92 looks looks a bit strange here
in this position with this bishop on a
form
mmm not really sure what I should do
well 92 there is c5 maybe and he's going
hmm c5 I'm afraid that I'm that he will
play c5 and it could be five and then
this is a very good banco with the
bishop being silly on a form but how do
i actually protects afore i don't really
see how I could sacrifice it it's not
it's not totally do take playing
something like and let's say Quincy one
but I really don't want to sacrifice a
pawn in this early in the game
maybe Quinn d3 is not so bad 2395 and if
I then retreated he's got a very weird
very weird nights nights you form very
tough okay let's check again Hagel 92 I
go 92 is playing c5 maybe I can just
take it that's yeah and i know i need to
play me I don't like this one very much
but there are other things I couldn't
get working 23 years 95 simply and he
can just take everything yeah the
question is now do I take on c6 to make
sure you don't get this weird banker
position what do I am just play let's
say rook B 1 a 3 before this kind of
idea but the bishop on f4 looks totally
totally bad for that ok I'm going to
take this is not brilliant but I don't
want this this weird banker stuff
this looks at least are quite solid okay
um name just shook c1 making sure that
that he can never really take on c3 and
continue from down the night is
obviously very silly on d2 now maybe
night p3 Queen d2 Bishop h6 this kind of
idea could be M could be on yeah it's
not it's not especially great but a
playable position nevertheless black
does not have any great acted plan
available at least I don't see one you
should think about his piece set up on
the queenside is there may be a
five-night c5 could be an idea then
develop the c8 bishop or just maybe also
just put the night back to f6 play but
should be 627 this erm also could be
quite a logical way to to set up the
pieces yeah he's taking a moment besides
some night x e6 there also was be take
c6 I don't think this was totally crazy
but he relatively quickly took with the
night there is some logic to it of
course because bulging the night is not
great and on a five so you want to
improve it ok I'll go here this has two
ideas Queen d2 and Bishop h6 and the
other idea is some maybe to get NC 5
from the right moment here there could
be a moment for this Bishop d7 is really
running into this idea
is just good now isn't it we're taking
on d6 if he takes there is my take c 5
which is excellent ready then the bishop
on f4 and everything makes perfect sense
and you cannot play d5 I was expecting
but should be six so that after c5 black
cam can play d 5 but you ignored the
idea yeah it looks really really bad now
it takes 95 yo you almost have to play
Bishop c8 back which is some really a
Bob as unattractive as it gets it's not
like immediately winning but very very
nice for white yeah just take it again
now probably Bishop c8 yeah he went for
that okay um just queen da droop do you
want as the normal move yeah come on
that's easy play play the easy moves
keeping the pressure on black can not
move the c8 bishop and I'm now
threatening Bishop takes c6 just
technically Bishop c6 look T 1 look t1b
sizzix rook da checking okay it's taking
voluntarily in a way yeah but what now
the idea here is to take on c6 and
playbook the eight Bishop f8 bishop age
6 and this should be a da game although
almost okay
I take it now Bishop c6 he takes on f4
Bishop rook rook the edge check push-up
f8 Bishop g7 push up to 7 97 hope the
898 yeah that that looks like it's
almost winning probably it is winning I
wonder if I should just play that or
look for something better the other
thing is you can easily be to maximal
istic in a way because there it's really
it looks like there should be a
something instantly here we go yeah and
if like Bishop g5 this is just excellent
I mean what exactly is black playing
after that but ok let's let's let's try
to calculate this to the end Bishop c6
young we take see Rock t8 is just just
not working at all or I can also take
your five so useless taking here takes
on f4 look THX bishop f8 Bishop takes b7
Bishop takes b7 night XP seven and he
cannot really avoid the Rope Ted rookie
898 and then after that the night is
coming to c 6 and then I get my king and
our canisters should be away now let's
let's do that
the key is that I get everything traded
down I mean back to a arm down to two
nights against a night ended bishop and
the night will come to see six at the
end where it has a very nice position so
that should be really really quite good
Bishop f8 quite good term that should be
should win now that I think of it what
about Bishop to d7 actually isn't thus
winning the exchange Bishop d7 on 97 97
s Bishop takes to sell net that's stupid
but Bishop c8 well Bishop d7 what about
that I les King g7 and c5 is hanging
groups emshab said okay that's not
convincing but something that was the
worst check worth checking out 97 this
Bishop d7 Brooke take Syed Bishop c6
okay so I'm going to take him I'm going
for my original line that the line that
I had to calculate it right at the start
but ok need to check every this is
critical and maybe there is something
better but i didn't i didn't find
anything better look 87 here I thought I
just go 95 and here it is always
important to check if this kind of night
on the rim has a safe way back and I
thought that that's always night c 6
which should be a good square and c6 is
also already looking at the promotion
square of the beep on which will add the
enter be pushed down the board okay I'm
not that maybe Bishop c5 trying for
Nyjah form now maybe
yeah i will try Bishop c5 year I guess
not sure if capturing this is really
helping much on g3 think I would
actually welcome that firm he takes
after H takes g3 I have an easy
continuation with e3 king of 1 e 2 D 3
and so on activating the king and
pushing the queenside pants if he
manages to somehow keep the pawn
therefore it's a bit more uncomfortable
ok I have kingi to f3 this is also not
bad now that's it's really very good for
what he does not have anything great
going for him
ok
yeah the nice thing is so that this is
some completely weakness free structure
that's absolutely no um weakness that
like an attack the only thing is like
Bishop c5 Nigeria die have just I can
just play III and stop all kind of
counter play and next will be 96 III
King to e2 and then be for a 4 and so on
okay is probably trying to push g5 h4
I'm going back with this it's not really
doing much on the 8th
and not sure maybe maybe also King to f3
could be an idea so that I have night
efore at the right moment yeah here I
can play before can start with that and
a for next this is quite quickly
advancing really yeah the way to to
promote this is actually not the B porn
but I can take this on c5 but it wasn't
okay it wasn't really a defendable
anyway black resigns yeah the the the
best way here to him to to advance us
actually to not try to promote the B
porn but promote the a pond so let's say
he's going here for example I'm going a
four a five and then be five so
something like that this is the way to
to go and this is already promoting or
across the bishop we should be six it's
not really helping but there is some
really nothing that black can do for
example just just to show what what
would have happened and here or maybe
just a six well this is just too good
the the pawn it is not promoting on its
own but i can i can at the end use the
King to get get into the center yeah the
main problem is that he allowed this c5
in which which was wrong button
here if black here just place and move
to to a counter this idea now Bishop b6
is one of them now after c5 it's got d5
and this is not not clear or I can play
that like this it's interesting but it's
not a big H or something there's also a
five-year also move it this is really
not working okay the computer points out
a good a good defense actually d5 yeah I
didn't see that that's an interesting
way to defend it's not great but it's
it's the relatively best try the idea
being that Knight takes Knight takes
Queen takes there is Bishop b2 and this
is not totally convincing for white I
think he should be a bit better but not
not winning or anything now with this
now is this is disastrous I mean
brilliant Qian Qian are we five yeah the
computer actually gives Bishop g5 as
being stronger even yeah I'm willing to
believe that I already said in the in
the life comments that this is probably
even better word okay I'm sorry wrong
button can I had seen the this this
thing and it says just it just looks
like it's totally winning and the
computers is merciless as usual it wants
to play night 5 2 e form hmm
is there a big problem with my move not
really it just the computer gives this
as plus 1.3 or something which is bit
conservative but it's it has this as
being completely winning interesting
yeah well the idea is to play Bishop d7
obviously cannot do that yes check I'm
quite funny at the end do this so black
is probably forced to take and now the
engine gives this as a total win
probably because I'm the wrist night a4
b6 95 b6 and black has no way to prevent
it this is the best line given either
machine and now the relatively best
defenses but should be six giving up in
exchange yeah okay this is this is of
course even somewhat better but this end
game frankly speaking is winning I mean
with good technique this is this is just
a winning endgame okay thanks for
watching